we're top troll we love music it makes
you want to wiggle your butt but there
are other trolls some of them can't even
grasp the concept of hammer time there
is a world full of different trolls like
reggaeton hip-hop not owe much care for
smooth jazz troll world tour does it
gotta be here
welcome to troll village trolls just
want to have fun we love music with a
hummable hook that's what makes us pop
tropes but we are not alone in this
world there are other kinds of trolls
[Music]
I'm queen barn of the hard rock trolls
I'm gonna destroy all music happy
birthday we have to unite all the trolls
prepare for battle this is the beginning
of a partnership between trolls is going
to say you roll who are you guys we're
the k-pop gang dance war fought Ealing
tango Sudhir's people our ancestors
created six streams each for different
type of music do I have all six strings
I'm gonna turn all the trolls into rock
zombies I can't leave we don't megaton
we're gonna have to go where no pop
drone has ever gone
without smiling trolls rule two or
twenty PG by the anyway World Tour I'm
gonna turn all the trolls into rocks
[Music]
[Music]
that was a crime against music I knew it
who let the dogs out too far trolls rule
- ready BG there are different kinds of
choice we need to make the queen of
rocks realize that it's all our
differences that we can world a richer
place we're gonna save the world we need
to unite all the trolls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well we're doomed to you I don't care
for smooth jazz the BG's here take the
ones you love to the happiest field we
make all the trolls on it well we're
doomed
[Music]
the trolls are back these other trolls
aren't like us
they sing different big dance different
roses troll throws as trolls Wow deep
the trolls are back destroy all music
[Music]
trolls world sewer
[Music]
into my world tumor I'm gonna destroy
all music except for Ross are we gonna
hug our way out of this one I won't
forget you no matter what pinky promise
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
you